hello girls it's really nice to see you  here what actually brought you here  today to some blues chess club  so we're uh out here uh supporting the  tournament that's going on right there  inside um we're especially here to  support hans um got our  fun little signs here and uh yeah just  out here to show our support we love him  create some buzz for the tournament in  general  you know it's a beautiful game and not a  lot of people know about it so we just  wanted to get some excitement going  outside the tournament chess is not  dead absolutely not that's for sure  right  would you like to make a surprise for  him  knows that you're here or not i don't  think he knows that we're here so i  really hope he comes out and sees us and  sees that he's got some fans out here  we haven't met him but we're really  hoping we get the chance too  [Music]